la pandémie qui a fait six cent mille
morts en russie le président encourage
la population à se faire vacciner mais
vladimir poutine n'impose rien pour
l'instant il a tenu ce jeudi sa
conférence de presse annuelle un rendez
vous attendu à l'international tant la
situation est étendue entre la russie et
les occidentaux à propos de l'ukraine
mais ce jeudi le ton est plus mesuré
coûté deux
prêtés aux morts pour l'heure nous
voyons une réaction positive nos
partenaires américains nous disent
qu'ils sont prêts à commencer ces
négociations dès le début de l'année à
genève les négociateurs des deux côtés
ont déjà été désignés j'espère que la
situation en ukraine évoluera dans ce
sens je n'y vois la lumière poutine qui
semble calmer le jeu mais c'est loin
d'être la fin de la crise la
correspondante à moscou d'elena
volochine
il faut noter qu'il a tout de même
envoyé un double message sur le crâne
d'un côté et il a une fois de plus
rappelé ses lignes rouges à savoir le
nom d'élargissement de l'otan aux deux
tiers de la russie et par là évidemment
à l'ukraine et de l'autre réductive mans
il a laissé entendre sa volonté de
laisser jouer la diplomatie et de ne pas
avoir recours à la force militaire il a
dit multiples en voir une dynamique
positive du côté de l'administration
américaine la balle est dans le camp de
l'otan at il affirmé alors prochaine
étape des pourparlers à genève dont les
représentants ont déjà été désignés
s'est réjoui le président russe alors
les futures actions de mouscou
dépendront clairement de se rendent deux
pour parler de leur issue est la
situation promet de ne pas être simple
puisque la russie a transmis à l'otan un
document avec ses propositions il
s'agirait pour l'otan de garantir un
futur un élargissement de l'alliance qui
évidemment a pour l'alliance est des
états unis est hors de question il
faudra négocier les termes d'une
potentielle entente entre moscou et
l'otan pour l'heure les dizaines de
milliers de soldats russes à massés à la
frontière ukrainienne son lac léman de
force de bladimir poutine pour
contraindre les occidentaux à négocier
cela a déjà marché en obligeant joe
biden à entendre la position entrée du
moins dans le dialogue avec vladimir
poutine sur la question ukrainienne ce
dialogue aboutira t-il il faudra le
suivre puisque ce mardi baydemir qui n'a
laissé entendre devant son état-major
qu'il n'excluait pas de d'avoir recours
à la force militaire si l'otan continué
selon lui a menacé la russie pour
conclure ce qu'on peut dire à l'heure
actuelle c'est qu'aucun scénario a donné
à exclure même si clairement de tous les
côtés dans tous les camps on préférait
ne pas avoir recours à l'escaladé
militaire